-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
We really do hope it's well.
Let's get to the news.
Former Trump lawyer
Rudy Giuliani has been banne
from practicing law
in the state of New York.
"I object,"
said people at his wedding
You see, guys, Rudy Giuliani's
wife, she wasn't, uh --
[ Laughter ]
She wasn't a normal wife.
She was, how do I explain --
Okay, so, you know how
you have cousins,
and then you know
how you also have someone
who's a wife,
and that's a different person?
Rudy Giuliani was like,
"Wouldn't it be more efficient
if they could be both?"
Former President Trump
reportedly told aides
that he hoped the coronaviru
would kill his ex-national
security adviser John Bolton
Luckily, Bolton had the wisdom
to grow his own N95.
He hasn't even had a cold
since the '90s.
That's right, former President
Trump reportedly told aide
that he hoped the coronaviru
would kill John Bolton.
"Oh, he was much more proactiv
with me," said Mike Pence.
Chairman of the joint chiefs
General Mark Milley yesterda
criticized Republicans
who opposed
the U.S. Military Academy
teaching critical race theor
and said, "I've read Mao Zedong.
I've read Karl Marx.
I've read Lenin.
That doesn't make me
a Communist." That's true,
but it does make him reall
annoying at college parties.
Republican Senator
John Kennedy yesterday
criticized
President Biden's plan
to address rising crime rate
and said, "Why is it safer
to walk down the streets o
Mogadishu than New York City?"
Well, that's easy.
Mogadishu doesn't have Revel
Microsoft this week
became the second U.S. company
to reach a market value
of $2 trillion.
But, remember,
the first was GameStop.
President Biden traveled
to North Carolina today
and visited a mobile
vaccination site.
It wasn't supposed to be mobile,
but they saw him coming.
"Oh, man, he's gonna tell
one of his stories.
Pick everything up.
Pick everything up."
Netflix has released a trailer
for its new dating show
called "Sexy Beasts,"
which features people wearin
animal masks and prosthetics
to go on dates.
But the show will face
stiff competition
from just going to bed already
And finally, today, soccer sta
Lionel Messi turned 34 years
o-o-o-o-o-o-l-l-l-o-o-o-o-ld
[ Laughter ]
We're going to take
a long break.
And that was the monologue
everybody!